good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials happy Monday
yay you know what I had a couple meets
to speak and they said we missed the
singing and you know what I heard your
cries ladies but you were gonna make
them work for it you knew that people
miss it but now you really need to make
them it said because now it's up to
those of you who missed it to combat
those who complain about it and you know
what what are you gonna try and stop me
from being myself no no don't let the
haters stop you from playing anything
oh yes deal with the fear of striking
out Savion oh you just merged too it was
like don't let the fear of that pocket
refuse stop you from playing the game no
also that's what that's when I really
realized like this you know my words
have impact because it was starting to
affect our podcast reviews and I'm like
really proud of our podcast reviews and
some people were saying negative things
about my singing so you know what I'll
[ __ ] stop but if people who like the
singing can you go counteract the bad
podcast erm yes please you know but okay
and then I'll give you what you want
totally um it feels like it's been a
month and a half since I last sat in
this chair so much has happened so much
has happened in the world but also in
the toast like I was basically replaced
because Olivia's episode was met with
such positive reviews more positive than
anything episode I've ever been a part
of but if you hosted once every three
months it would be like Cuddy is great
but no but like every time I'm she
should be a permanent every time right
every time I'm gone let's the most
hurtful things right okay so every time
I and they said that about everyone
except for joey camasta but every time
i'm gone and there's a co-host like
taylor's record aaron whatever like the
usual head Oh [ __ ] Heather's coming
for my job right so just stop saying
that okay like shower everyone in all
the comments you want that's just like
the one that hurts the most
right and like I see it like I read it
like Olivia's truly coming for my job
that her episode was like the best day
of everyone's [ __ ] life while like I
was looking up at 6:00 a.m. getting on a
plane so I get to serve serve premium
content at night and it was just really
hurtful okay it's circle and I I
understand
and we love you and we miss you dearly
and we do what we can while you're gone
and we were just glad that we were able
to rise to the challenge no like in the
comments right now people aren't even
saying sorry they're not starting was
the best episode like they said I
watched him four times she's the voice
of the toasters she watched it four
times so it's settled I have to kill my
sister and you know what it's fine it's
fine
okay you know maybe like one time you
and Olivia show us I feel like mix it up
but that would have to be in the mix it
again that wouldn't mean me having to be
here and like that's just hard for me I
know so um because no week is complete
whenever I start to feel guilty like
that cuz this week we're doing four
episodes there's no show Friday coz I'm
headed to Mexico TBD on show Friday
oh it's reliant on one snitch oh yeah if
she is here on Friday we show if she's
not we're off cuz it's a holiday weekend
okay well even when I start to feel
badly I'm like oh it's four shows out of
five like the podcasts were competing
with do [ __ ] one show a week like
their life is so easy
totally I don't feel bad actually I do
you do how much a week with nephews week
out I was hoping you would ask
so for those who don't know I was gone
all weekend Wednesday Sunday and then
was gone too on Zak's bachelor party
does actual party even though none of
them get the hash tag right there's no
picture so we didn't know what to do
with Theo and Jackie finally took him
just so does Jackie's been thinking
about getting a dog she wanted to test
it out go
so nephews again that was a huge success
like I had him for a really long time
for a first-time sleepover at ants you
know I never spent the day with him but
you haven't spent the night he's never
sucked at Auntie kisses so it was really
so wonderful we had the greatest time it
wasn't any more or less work than I
anticipated but it did solidified my
position that I will not be getting a
dog anytime soon really because I love I
love the takes so much but I really am
so germ conscious like I'm on turbo
phobic I'm germ aware like if I see him
pee on the back of his paws I watched
her pee trail through my house end up on
the couch print over there print and I'm
just too aware of the germs and New York
City living is not meant for me and a
dog and every time he went to the
bathroom he came in I washed his paws
and I was happy to do it because it was
NWO but I can't live my whole life like
that like Theo was really in
this weekend whatever he wanted to do we
were doing it like Saturday I didn't
make any plans
it was just Theo's weekend and I can't
have some embossing me around like that
forever
so Leo is gonna have to wait maybe you
know when I move to the burbs and I can
just open that thing that door where
they can just run out yeah you know and
then they're just going in regular grass
and coming in so it's the concrete that
makes his paw wet because the grass when
a dog pees in the grass it just absorbs
right up but natheles peeing in a puddle
of his own urine yes there's no [ __ ]
grass in New York yeah so every time he
went out he came in and he was it was
like just way too smelly for me and like
I loved him so much and and I embraced
this - but I I can only do so much you
know I almost bought a - Shark Tank
product last night because of that that
handheld hose oh did you watch that yeah
I started to and it was so bad I shot
well I saw it on your store and I'm like
oh Jackie's talking about it maybe
talked about on the show so I just
turned it on it was like this handheld
little gadget and they turned down an
offer it was actually you know watch I
don't know I don't even I don't care
about slobber was being so Robert like
okay ready he was being like kind of
like a control so Robert Bethany and
Damon all wanted this product Robert had
25% for the amount of money when Bethany
and Damon each offered 30% so the guys
are like okay Bethany and Damon would
you go in together like they totally out
and Robert was like you know fine I'll
do 30 like everyone else and they need
to [ __ ] care Robert kept changing is
D like they weren't interested
so the second the guys were like Bethany
and Damon Robert ran out and he's like
was all butt hurt and then he wouldn't
stop butting in like it he was so upset
she was like you show her in Maya so
then they were like then they focused on
Damon and Bethany was all about her so
she went out so then that's really about
her I know and and it's like that's what
happened her and mark mark and Robert
like we're being kind of mean to her she
was like being so chatty and they were
like just get to it and she was like I
have to sit through your [ __ ] all
day let's shut up and let me talk but it
was actually getting kind of contentious
I don't think that they like are loving
Bethany because she comes I'm strong and
in the first episode she was on that
like lassies and I think she just like
eased her right into it and then got
really good reception so now she's like
being more of like a bull Vaughn but
like with every pic she feels like she
has something to prove and like she
comes in
it's like no one even disrespect her and
she feels disrespected because she's on
real house yeah like she has this own
complex that every time there's a new
pitch we go through it again where she
feels she needs to prove herself thirty
million women watching her show and it's
like if you're a shark you're beyond
proving yourself yeah I know like Mark
doesn't I don't even know what Mark does
he's right Ella no but I want him as my
shark right like because you don't need
to prove yourself totally and I just
felt like it just the pitches may be
America's entrepreneurial spirit has
been drained I mean it has been ten
seasons of ten years of shark yeah but
the pitch is just what have gone done
down what was the product that you said
was terrible cuz I didn't get there you
had a product that I thought was
terrible I was it was the first one the
adventure the Challenger I didn't I
didn't start tuning in until I start
your stories right like the [ __ ] it's
just like a scavenger hunt thing and the
pitch was just weird and I was just like
feeling uncomfortable and I was like
what is going on like this isn't premium
this is it just wasn't premium and there
was nothing wrong with it there it
sounded like a fine product
I just mean I was just in a weird mood
and I didn't feel like watching okay but
it also it felt off there was mr.
wonderfully not know if there was
something and then Robert wasn't Kevin
Robert was in marks seat
you know that wasn't Kevin so Robert
threw me off so see that's what I was
saying last week when we were talking by
charging Robert is butthurt obviously
that he always is in the end chair
because you get the least amount of face
time so he's like [ __ ] I want the
best charity check marks chair but mark
is an N chair - it's not the best chair
Marko's in the middle - what what's
happening because Kevin's gone I guess
mark is number two mark Kevin's chair
middle chairs the best chair and Roberts
just got moved to another side to
probably make you feel better I think
that no difference between Robert and
Mark's chair yes there is because the
cameras
Robert is the farthest away there's no
camera on the other side of Robert do
you know what I mean Martin physically
closer so mark boy even when they're
showing just all five of them mark is
the foreground
Robert you can't even see you I think
Kevin has the best chair enough I think
mark and Kevin are the best chairs sure
sure and I think Robert like now that
he's all like skinny and he's snatched
and has like a new girlfriend and [ __ ]
like he wants the front chair at first
when he was just like old grandpa over
there like nobody care but now maybe
some Dancing with the Stars and he's got
a tight ass and he wants the front seat
and also he shows that for every episode
so like he's the hardest-working man on
Shark Tank know but he's like because of
all the Sharks he probably has the least
going on which is fine he really is able
to show up for work all the time so he
should get a little more leverage in
more he also shows up for work all the
time but she's a lot going on
yeah okay she can do it all I don't want
to talk about shark tank because like I
what didn't even watch it you know yeah
well we're talking about NWO and so that
is subverted for now very sad but it did
make me realize I'm happy to take the
takes whenever you need for a while I
was always like I'll take him for the
day but he can't sleep over but I will
take and you guys he didn't have any
accidents boy but that was also just a
testament to I really adhered to the
schedule
I doubt a full itinerary daily itinerary
for Jackie just to let him know schedule
cuz you know you don't realize like the
dog like high schoo the bathroom all the
time no and he was very on schedule and
by the way I didn't realize but he
speaks fluent English because he was
taking a nap and I just said you know do
you want to go outside
pops up runs to the door stands by his
coat I was like so there's two things
that you say this do that he understands
but I I think it more has to do with the
way that I say it cuz I'm like still
wanna go out and he sprites up ghosted
or also say do you want to eat runs to
the kitchen doesn't he'll only listen to
those things but the thing I didn't say
with that sort of uh you didn't flection
I just was like casual like hey it takes
like do you want to go outside and he
missed like mid nap um well I'm glad you
had such a great week cuz you want to
know why I had an amazing week really
like but maybe one of the best weeks on
tour of my life really let me tell you
why I've been having I was on a three
week break and it's like a hard I
thought it was not gonna remember any of
my show like whatever I land him in
Cincinnati natty Islands and then addy
just amazing crowd I did so great and
like it was just great to to get back
into things like because the better the
more reps I do have the show the better
I am but like I haven't been on first
one weeks of my last two shows in Miami
were like a month ago
so Cincinnati [ __ ] it's like I slayed
him i slayed them and I was like upset
I'm like great now we can only go
downhill from here you know men myanmar
group didn't spend the night in
Cincinnati me we made the two-hour drive
to Columbus and we got to wake up in
Columbus and sleep in and it was just
like brilliant routing on behalf of my
team it wasn't my idea I can't take
credit for just thing like waking up in
Columbus
truly truly such a great hotel lemme
Rhydian very fancy it was a Jacob hotel
whatever Joseph hotel sorry so glad just
had a great day in Columbus then I had a
show in Columbus and I thought
and killed it again I was just like I
was on it and there was I was making
such good like Midwest jokes and what
was so funny is like do they say that
Columbus is the Paris of America I
didn't know that so I was just like
making so many jokes about because I
thought it was except a loser he thing
to say then I had a day off and we
travel to Detroit and they didn't
realize like the whole week but Detroit
was to date my biggest show I didn't
realize that literally until the middle
of your show and someone said it I have
no clue I know the biggest show was like
a stood plant
yeah and Atlanta those were the biggest
ones and I try not to think of it like
doctors and I put like pressure on how
much bigger was it was like 50 more
people than Boston okay but you have to
think of Boston like you're gonna City
the venue like I was so surprising like
a thousand people can fit in here it was
like tiny as hell you know what I mean
this was like a full-blown but I feared
yes I mean mezzanine two levels and just
like why this hell so once I got there I
was like wait how many people is this
and then I realize this may be the
biggest show and like I start to have a
pit you know and I was there like four
hours early and was just like stamping
the couch because Kacey Musgraves was
there the day before and also I stayed
at the Motor City casino which was
glamorous Helen I won $500 it was just
like a great week for me you know
actually I took out $200 I gave Margit
100 and like homegirl lost it which was
annoying but then I turned my 100 into
five so technically I'm only up 300 but
a win is a win
you know I don't vote for 200 I left
with five okay okay are my own 13 inch
loss 100 on my hundred I made four was
that part of her pay no if we could
write it off she wasn't gonna play and
then write it off
totally she did want to play and I wanna
play by myself I'm like god it was like
it's my own thing but one of my agents
was there and he tickets two brothers
Osbourne and he was like you guys wanted
to go do the sisters house sure you want
to go two brothers I I don't think he
was expecting us to be like yeah we do
get out and we were like we literally
paid the bill by dinner I'm like no
let's go and we ran and they were
amazing first of all one of them is so
[ __ ] hot like the most handsome man
I've ever seen in my life and the other
is just like Chris Stapleton vibes yeah
there's something for everyone there's
something for everyone and if I'm sure
all you people to argue at the other one
is hotter yeah I feel like a battery
from it's a matter of taste but no they
sound I was listening to iTunes like
they were so good and like I was
honestly like I was I wish I'd known I
was going earlier cuz I would have like
done everything I can to try and meet
them but like I was texting people like
last minute people are like
I'm out like you know but I only knew
like maybe four or five songs and they
were just so good like I could I don't
know what I was more impressed with like
how hot that guy was or how good they
were like and they were just so they're
so into the music like the instrumental
you know but then I was telling somebody
to tell you
so my Detroit show it was great they had
a big toasty pregame before and it was
like right upstairs and I couldn't go I
was like what I was gonna do like get
drunk before my show right so I sent my
credit card up there and brought like a
hundred shots for everyone and I was
just like watching right now I I was
just watching the videos of these
bartender these poor bartenders like
pouring 100 shots of fireball for
everyone like the toasters are being so
funny
against my showing you know I'd like to
do research before I'm like reading
things about Detroit you know Saddam
Hussein has a key to the city in Detroit
like it was there there was such
interesting facts you know what a fact I
read was yeah they call Detroit the
Paris of about both of them of the
Midwest are in the of America yeah okay
Wow and I'm like you know that they say
that doesn't deny detail okay but so
which one do you think is the Paris oh
good question it was Columbus or Detroit
Columbus very nice yeah it was just like
and I think I did such a great show in
Detroit like I'm just feeling like so
confident am i show now and it was just
like a really it was a growth week for
me
Wow nothing like a week of growth and
then I got home to my son which was just
a good happiness you know your son who
had had a week of happiness a week of
growth too with that strug you know you
all know who he was really happy oh he's
so cute we walked to OC all weekend
honestly what if he's a much COC and he
thought Marissa's an idiot and I have a
controversial take that Theo actually
agree with me that Seth Cohen is like so
annoying and immature instability yeah
if you really watch it like he's just
like illogical and so self-centered it's
like he thinks he's like self-aware so
he it makes it okay right but it's
really not well so I'm watching Heart of
Dixie mhm and it's just so funny cuz the
only thing I really ever seen rachel
bilson in is summer Roberts but she's
the greatest thing ever
and she's the most beautiful and just
like I'm like I just love her like
whatever she's so [ __ ] annoying and
heard of Dixie like I could slap her
upside the head she's always making the
wrong decisions
and like her face is just like so upset
all the time like she's just annoying as
[ __ ] but that's the thing about any show
it's like the protagonist has to make
bad choices in order for them to be like
to grow and be interesting and so on
until I am ever auditioning for a show I
don't want the starring role no I want
the I want some I want to be summer
Roberts
yeah even though I want to be lemon
Breeland totally totally even though
she's only started piss me off now so is
George but like I have to I I I might
start watching next I need a new show
I'm literally watching garbage I tried
to start watching succession on HBO oh
because like the name sounds similar to
dynasty yeah I thought it was a similar
thing and like it was so weird it was
like dynasty if it were written written
by like Wes Anderson's like Oh God yep
brother I'm sorry was like dropped on
his head I do not [ __ ] with Wes Anderson
like whatsoever I will never get those
two hours of my life when I saw that
movie about the kids and the Girl Scouts
and the house and the moon and the
rising moon rising the girl looks like
Alexandra LaBelle actually the girl was
so pretty and that was like the only
part of the movie that I could stand but
like them in the tent like no it was the
worst movie I ever saw
and like I'll never watch another Wes
Anderson movie even if someone said to
me this will be the most amazing movie
even if I said it to you and I'll give
you a million dollars I still wouldn't
do it even if I yeah who gives you good
recommendations who's never led you
astray never even if I said it yeah and
good thing I don't have any Wes Anderson
movie circa man I once rented the grand
Budapest hotel trash because the poster
is key was cute yeah it's good for art
in your apartment I didn't even get
through the credit the opening credits
I'm sorry like I'm just there's a
certain type of viewer for Wes Anderson
and I'm the opposite of it oh great so
that's why succession and it was like if
we were written by like Aaron Sorkin and
Wes Anderson had a baby who then you
know just went nuts yeah and then just
got you know to write a script because
his parents are important by the way so
then I was like okay you know I'll just
watch you I see okay yeah okay I feel
like we've shot the [ __ ] enough long
enough so we can dive in for sure
I just had one last thing hyper about
NWO the week oh the other change that
occurred while you were gone you're a
man my hair Oh totally and
like cuz I already keep up like on
social media so I forgot about it right
and but we already spoke about it a
little so obviously you've all noticed
thank you that I've been switching up my
hairstyle this is now day three of
wearing it in this half-up half-down
you've been a side part Steen what for
like five or ten years I've been a side
card scene since I got my original law
back in 2015
okay so this has been a big change and I
sort of speak to how it occurred very
briefly but Wednesday night I got my
hair done by glam squad I asked for
loose waves and what I wound up getting
was it looked like I put my hair in a
wet braid let it dry and then took it
out so it was like straight up top like
crimped yeah and then straight ends and
like I didn't even realize how bad it
was until I saw pictures of it the next
day like it was just it was awful
however by the next day it really did
have like this loose wave effect and
then I put on this like camel colored
sweater with my Anna Sui fur boots and I
had kind of a hippie ish vibe going with
my loose waves and it was like and I you
know who I have to thank for this Theo
because Theo woke me up so early every
single day especially when I was doing
the toast with his like he was like this
was Theo he he wakes me up with his fake
sneezes in his licking his lips I'm like
I go look at him he's like oh you're up
yeah let's go you're up - who's that
with you
so anyways each day I was like I had so
much time to get ready which I never do
so I started experimenting with
hairstyles I almost did this hairstyle
that I always do but then it didn't look
at and I was like you know let me just
try and like put it back so what are you
holding it with in the black for bobby
pins Oh so it's pretty loose so it it
makes it less like rigid um and it was
just it really came off well on camera
was so well received by the audience
that I reenacted it for Friday cuz I
still have that hairdo you go like I
hadn't washed my hair yet and then today
I wanted to do it again for people I
think it looks great and it makes my
hair look even longer
yes it you can really see the growth
that I've been working on for four years
ya know watch it for a year it looks
great
thank you isn't it so crazy that like
most of the hair on your head
like you didn't have like yesterday like
a year ago yeah or isn't it so crazy
that like I use of goodly long hair and
wear extensions and I had to cut it so
short in order to get the length and
volume
that I once had you know no I know and I
feel like I've always pride my pride in
myself and like never ironing my hair
and like just being like natural healthy
hair but like now iron my hair almost
every day and like I also ordered almost
a thousand dollars and things from
revolve it's like I don't know who I am
anymore people grow and change it see
it's a week of growth I do it so
apologize to everyone who's trying to
order something in a size large on
revolve because it's gone because I took
it and you know they like only have one
in stock
totally Oh an extra large good luck like
there was none I feel like they put the
extra-large button on revolve as sold
out just permanently like they never
even had it but they don't want to get
[ __ ] for not being size inclusive but no
they'll have extra extra small that's
crazy
who the [ __ ] Nicole Richie is the only
person who's extra small because you
have to be small in weight and small in
height petite so extra you have to be
extra extra small now I get it
oh also I got to meet so many premium
toasters on my trip I met Jordan Vic who
by the way it's like admin for the
Michigan toaster she really like got the
group together and mr. Meighan do you
know mr. Meighan okay mr. Meighan is a
new toaster and I've he came to my
attention by his premium [ __ ]
comments on the toast Instagram that
always rise to the top because he gets
so many likes and then he started
tagging all those in scream stories him
and his friend roadtrip five hours for
my show and he didn't have a minger
e-ticket I might get that [ __ ] into
the main great got to meet him and like
first of all he's so handsome second of
all it was just like it was really a
special moment so they do his comments
Yeah right and I think you spoke about
him once before yeah um a picture in a
bowtie on his Instagram and I just got
to meet some of so many premium toasters
I was really grateful to meet Jordan Vic
and the hard work of all the girls who
moderate the Royal Oak Michigan toasters
group like they are a strong group Wow
like they had a 200-person pregame where
they also raised 600 ollars for a local
women's shelter like that is [ __ ] and
then they came in sequence and we're in
the first row and we're being so [ __ ]
premium I saw them the whole time and
they were just like giving me such good
energy it's like hard to be in the first
row to be like funny and loud but not
annoying and like distracting and they
were just like the most premium [ __ ]
first row [ __ ] well I'm so happy to
hear that yeah I was really I said I
said whatever it is I'll match it and
we'll double it
I gotta get a contact okay well are you
ready for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast I'm
literally getting look at this you say
oh I mean I always shed but you ever
like lose so much hair like another one
it's like the concern ooh yes no um it
has to do with the changing of the
seasons and I lose up here when I don't
wash it for a few days it's very normal
because I lose so much hair I said like
more than Theo honestly and look look
how great my hair is growing no I know
I'm like so jealous of your hair what
your hair's like way thicker but mine's
like breaking now and it does exciting
time like a new hair going on yeah yeah
you know I'm happy for you thank you
know that I am even if I like don't
understand know that I know I didn't oh
yeah even if I like don't understand you
know because I'll see the pain and then
what's next
oh yeah you're saying reel me in my
heart like let me get through that's all
though I'm happy for you that was good
it felt terrible no good I was looking
at four stories this morning and by the
way there is just great some really
great stories and there was one and it's
like upsetting because as someone who's
looking for stories this morning I knew
that there were great stories in this
world and there was one that was about
an Instagram post that Demi Lovato liked
Demi Lovato likes Instagram post about
sobriety okay well well Jordan TARTA
quotes the same jacent arctic followed
me in answer him where's my ass weekly
story I'm sure it's coming because
they'll just write anything okay first I
change my mind about him what was what
were you thinking before but vampire oh
you know he used to be a vampire I like
him but only to higher but now like that
I've been following him and Caitlin's
like journey to love I'm here for it I
was a member and not here for it he's no
I was just like I was always like who
was this man you know who said and watch
the season I'm like why is everyone so
obsessed them and then I feel like
threatens when people like know things
that I don't know you know
and now I've invested and I'm I
officially get my thumbs up even though
like nobody cares but like I say I love
Edward Colin even though he's a man
right yes no no but it was like the only
episode I watched of that season was him
being a vampire in his hometown you know
but like he was a man here like anything
changed his hair now like I'll never
forget what he doesn't have the vampire
I was like little curly scar I didn't
like Fagin widow's peak yeah no no it
was the little little pay us coming out
and that was all I saw and I'm like this
is America's Sweetheart but now I'm
following a little bit since we all love
Twilight right but now I'm following
along he's just like such a gentleman
Caitlin is Bella Bella no and Caitlin
like is a good judge of character
like she except for the whole Nick thing
but she's a good judge of character and
if she likes him I like him and I
officially like him here for it I mean
just like Edward totally but also just
like I was here for Jacob is the way
that I'm here for you know Colton I'm so
here for Colton even though like I don't
know if I'll be able to take like I've
such a long busy day I don't I can't
imagine ending it with the bachelor I
agree we'll get well you know what no
pressure okay
also I can't laugh because I'm sore but
I rented the love muffin because I
didn't let my think yesterday some of
them and now start working out cuz you
know how we say like I'm so soft I'm
gonna try and like your your milk Oh
dick I'm gonna try and like really like
tone up a little okay before the wedding
because if I don't like if not now when
but your whole body's covered in the
wedding just do your arms yeah but then
it's like if I'm going to do my arms I
might as well do the rest my body and
like look okay like look nice and
amazing soon like I guess I don't know I
just thought like if I'm ever gonna do
it in my life it's gonna mean yeah so
let's just see let's see what I would
look like if I tried to like firm up all
right okay first story breaking the
internet this egg beat Kylie Jenner's
Instagram record with now 29 million
lights check this morning the Internet
just told Kylie to go suck an egg
is that other didn't and who wrote that
Pete page six Mirko a simple photo of a
single brown egg has overtaken the
youngest kardashian-jenner at the most
like Instagram post of all time with
more than 29 million likes and Counting
and setting a world record the photo to
beat was an image of newborns stormy
originally posted on February 6 2018
with just 18 point 3 million likes the
golden egg uploaded to the Instagram
account world record egg on January 5th
took less than two weeks to surpass the
model and lipstick mogul
then Kylie when she saw that you know
the I could beat her she posted this
meme of her frying an egg on a hot
cement sidewalk so here's my question do
we know who's behind the egg no but the
egg follows you I know so I'm like do I
know them I don't think they I think
they follow like 900 people probably you
know real movers and shakers no just
like people with my good like engagement
that they had yeah or like people that
they wanted to notice them did you like
the put forth a one-take knew about it
which by the way I didn't know about
until afterward already passed the bow I
remember like two days ago
that's so I guess it's cause like I'm
not on Twitter and it was and it wasn't
on Twitter it was really on Instagram I
guess was an NWO thing we were I was
just busy like on the premium content
side of it not on the premium you know
engagement side yeah so what I'm happy
for the egg this is kind of funny and
cool and I just I'm down what do you
think anyone will ever beat the ad 27 29
million right so it's not like I mean
Kylie at 18 was like huge and now
there's such a big gap between the first
and the second it'll be a lot before
this person what are you what would have
to happen I don't know like maybe if
Kylie posted a wedding photo of her and
Travis where she's like in a white dress
you know there are very few people who
could do it it would be Kylie can it
might be Kim it could be Taylor Swift
it could be Selena gonna give me
Christian Aldo Ronaldo Nicodemus is the
Christian of Christian Christiano
Ronaldo Giada
it could be Selena Gomez if she like
ever posted something that wasn't a
blurry picture or not or an ad or a lie
you know like if it was a picture like
hey guys I'm back from rehab because I'm
off of heroin now like that would get it
right no or if it was a picture of her
just like being like cute in a
restaurant like that's not sponsored you
know ya know like he posted that one one
real-life photo yeah or like if she went
to if she like I don't know synced up
with like revolves photographers oh my
god Beyonce could get it if she put the
footage of Solange with audio ooh you
know then then she'd probably win most
viewed and people don't like like people
view videos but then they were like like
that totally totally so what's like a
looks like the 8th wonder of the world
like we'll never know like if Amelia
Earhart made an Instagram and know she
blew any less don't care about Amelia
hurt she's the 8th wonder of the world
where did she go the 8th wonder of the
world is what happened in that elevator
the 8th wonder of the world is who
killed Johnny Ramsay a story that you
missed but that the
I said he did even though I'm not
believing on I'm believing it has anyone
ever confessed this is the question I
posed has I guess a lot of people have
confessed to the murder of Jon Benet has
anyone who was a suspect ever commit
confessed
yeah like random people confess all the
time yeah I did it right but that but he
was actually a suspect and now he's
confessing and it's an old confession
also did you see the side by side
someone putting the toasters of Hannah
gee from The Bachelor looking like Jon
Benet cuz she totally does for sure but
anyone who's just like pretty they put
side by side with Jon night Katy Perry
Wow I've literally never been put next
to Jon Benet and now I'm upset and the
toasters have failed me
thank you like no one actually looks in
fact it's just like me pretty child
pretty and you also see someone put in
the toasters that Hannah G has been in
like four or five country music videos
yes did you watch them no okay when was
the last time you did something for the
first time Darius Rucker the cutest
music video of all time it's like Hannah
Jean meets this guy to party and then
they like have his whole life together
like have kids he does a keep this
[ __ ] music video then she was in a
bunch of others like Thomas red and some
other one we're like they literally
refused to show her face and I didn't
care interesting I'm just still trying
to think abut refined roots in Yelm
won't be and geo multi was in that
middle of a memory doesn't maybe they
made an exact same agent for music video
bookings maybe I think I'm just so
excited for Hannah gee I don't know if
she wins or not I don't think she does
but I think she was meant for her post
Bachelor life is just gonna be so she's
such a bright future like let's see how
many Instagram followers she said I
think she's probably at like 150 no no
okay so when I checked during the
episode she was at 120 like a day later
she's got 150 and then a week later she
was at 180 so now see this was like a
couple days ago 190 okay
yes she'll hit him if she goes sorry
she'll hit a million yes she deserves it
she was posting premium content so like
she's gonna get so many sponsorships and
like I could see her with the country
music star no totally she'd gift
definitely gives me like a Lauren B
trajectory I'm so excited to see what
she does next like she was doing like
red dress boutique which a lot of people
like really like apparently sharpton I
never heard of it but like she'll be
doing revolve soon oh my god of course
and I'm just so excited no like not
gonna lie I'm like jealous cuz she's so
pretty but she is I think the most
beautiful girl I've ever seen in my life
and I'm like butthurt that she doesn't
follow me I'm not on TV like wait till
you ever see her in person and it
translates right exactly great and if
the camera adds ten pounds I'm so afraid
to see her in real life okay are you
ready for a next story I don't know if
you even know this yet the Chris Pratt
is engaged to Catherine Shore
I dunno cuz I follow captain
schwarzenegger on instagram you did she
follows me she's like our age how would
you feel if your father based on your
age I thought it was you walk into the
front door so would you make a clip of
that look like imagined and Real
Housewives of Orange County like Kelly
and Shannon really could someone make
that for me please I don't know how to
do that Chris Pratt put a ring on it a
huge one on Monday the star announced
his engagement to girlfriend Catherine
Schwarzenegger quote sweet Catherine's
so happy you said yes I'm thrilled to be
marrying you
wait quickly do you think energy wears
an extra small an extra extra small an
obnoxious mom I know what they're having
inclusive yeah okay it's fine proud to
live boldly in faith with you here we go
he got shun Instagram the couple
reportedly met through Schwarzenegger
mother Maria Shriver and has been dating
since osteo pride and Schwarzenegger 29
the daughter of Arnold Schwarzenegger
made their relationship Instagram
official in December when the actor
posted a photo collage in honor of her
birthday okay okay you know what's so
funny he's like I didn't know that he
had posted that collage but like this
gives me like Harry and Megan vibes like
I'd heard a lot about these two people
dating
I wasn't sure like they never really
actually confirmed it and then now
they're married like that was Harry a
medic yeah like I didn't take it too
seriously you know because he could be
dating like anyone and actually I did I
took it decently seriously but I just
can't believe he's engaged when he got
divorced like a year ago no I know I'm
like now I have a pit and feel sad for
cuz I actually had a dream that Ben left
me and when I was away on tour and it
was like really sad and then he like had
a girlfriend and then I was thinking
about like him having sex with this girl
I'm like I let her woke up crying cuz
like me men have only had sex with each
other like please do not taint us with
some sort of STD like what if we get
back together and then like you had to
and I only had one you know if you it
was so like then I had and now I like
like it's like Lynette and Tom like I
had the biggest pit for Lynette when he
was out frolicking with Jane and all
that other stuff so when when a man who
was like a family like marry someone I
was like I know it's like normal life
like it makes me really sad for the
woman who's like at home
bearing their children yes or a child in
this case this is the one yeah I think
his name is Jack is a little man okay I
thought there was more than one but
still but still uh it's a sad and this
not that it's like Russia or anything
cuz he could do whatever he wants and
they seemed like there
happy and really normal and like there's
nothing weird going on I did like
picnics in the park but it's like what's
the rush she got engaged are they gonna
have more kids oh my god it I guess
she's 29 like she's sprites and she's
bright like this is her first marriage
why should she be do that totally Wow
it's really crazy also I am watching OCI
I did start season 4 because I was
actually thinking without Marissa it
might be more enjoyable and Chris Pratt
is in it
what dysplasia hey that annoying brown
kid who was like trying to save the
world you know okay I'm sorry I was like
know what I thought no I can't go to
brown yeah I was like I like there's no
way my sister just said that like I know
you you would never see Rosa browny
bigotry younger that annoying brown
students okay Brad yeah okay big
difference
god I'm so weird he really like Rose the
ring he was in that movie five-year
engagement he was in Bride Wars cuz he
yes he played like the funny fat guy for
like a million roles and then like got
snatched and that was a movie star in
Jurassic Park yeah so like he really he
paid his dues and now he's marrying
Katherine Schwarzenegger I kind of ship
it and I think they also bond they like
go to the same church and they're like
deeply religious well she said and it's
here cuz he had like a three sentence
Instagram caption and he and he said he
thinks he went to say meet Katherine so
happy you said yes okay and now
engagement Alison I'm thrilled to be
marrying you thank you for clarifying on
the engagement what she said yes too
proud to live boldly and faith with you
it sounds like a line from Justin Bieber
yeah bro but like that's that Oh like
that's what was second most important to
his blood faith that's nice yeah and
there must be what they bond it over
yeah she's a premium ass Instagram but
she never post about him so maybe that's
why I didn't know that they were
official cuz I don't follow
I don't follow Pratt Pratt Pratt me
neither like I'm just I'm not like a
Chris Pratt stand like everyone else's
once in once upon a time I was I don't
know what changed
I liked that Christ what happened yeah I
liked that Chris Pratt like he was
relatable he was cute he was still the
type I thought that he was like the type
of guy like I would have gone for but
like skinny girls Pratt I just can't
relate to him like Tunisia
and I've heard he's like a dick oh
really yeah like like major like diva
vibes but also like I have fake sources
and that could be totally not true true
well hopefully you know she'll bring out
the best in him when was the last time
you know as she definitely seems like a
good homemaker to like a Balabushka I I
don't know anything about her I look
forward to getting to know her you know
she's premium as hell she's like a rich
kid you know she went to USC sure
because she was there when Zach was
there oh so she says could have been
Zach could've been Zach right
when he told me that I was it oh my god
she's our age she was like in his grade
or like that really shook things up from
the perspective of like grades it's big
Chris Pratt is marrying someone who
would like went to college with who was
it like who could have went to college
with me like that's crazy that's how I
feel about like Camila Mendez and Maggie
Rogers like we were all of him on you at
the same time and like they got super
famous like how did I miss out back down
no toilet and not only do you not get
super famous wasn't I'm friends with
them right that's the real myth maybe it
was cuz like I never went to school and
I lived at home like that could've done
it maybe I don't know I wouldn't maybe
if I had spent more than five minutes on
campus I don't know okay speaking of
wedding bliss former bachelor ari lined
at junior marries more and burnham oh my
god I love them so much
ari lion Dyke Junior is no longer about
her on Saturday the former bachelor
married fiance Lauren Burnham in front
of a hundred guests in Maui Hawaii the
couple who met on season 22 of ABC's
long-running reality show got engaged
last March during the after the final
rose special following his breakup with
Becca okay you all watch morton toast
you know what happened Yeah right
okay I love it they were so open and
like they were just like like I knew it
was the day they were getting married it
wasn't like a surprise I was following
along I was looking at her tag pictures
the whole day she didn't even look
pregnant she looked amazing and the one
photo that they released had two
pictures had two girls in the background
both wearing away what are your thoughts
on that I my thoughts are that it was a
Hawaii wedding so I think it was that
I'm sure the dress code was like light
and white you know like your knives what
people mentioned that one of the people
was Hayley Paige who designed the
welders a wedding dress and she clearly
knows wedding etiquette
it was encouraged for people to wear
white Mike yeah no I don't think that's
like a big deal anymore and at my
wedding people were like giving Corinne
[ __ ] she wore like a light pink and in
person it didn't look anything like
white but I guess in pictures it did and
they were like leaving the meetings
comments on her Instagram like I don't
even [ __ ] care and it wasn't even
real
and I don't think that's a real role no
I think like if you're a bridesmaid like
and you can wear whatever you want and
like you wear white that's weird I just
I don't even wear white but like light
like light pink cleany vibe something
that's white with other [ __ ] going on is
fine yeah it's like if someone could
wear this dress as a wedding dress like
on the beach somewhere no but like if it
just happens to have white in it okay
the Hayley Paige is dressed 100% is a
wedding dress
yes but I think that like Warren
probably told people that it was okay to
wear white like because she doesn't seem
like an uptight kind of gal no their
wedding looked really cute it's it and
the pictures that I'm seeing like it
looked really nice I mean I think they
do pretty well well Ari like does actual
money like real estate money they have
Instagram money which can prove to be
very lucrative they have um his family
has money Oh does his dad it's like a
race but like he's a race car driver but
his dad was like I mean or so like
they're like in the good graces of The
Bachelor franchise so they have a bright
future when it comes to ABC money and
ever they also like God first of all
it's only 100 people in Hawaii
I'm sure the resort like subsidized out
of it I'm sure they they did okay and
then I was talking about this with um
snitch do we think Chris Harrison paid
his way down there like they had to fly
him out or like ABC like who covered
Chris Harrison's bill um I think he used
his his corporate card okay other saying
like I think he probably paid himself
like it's because it wasn't televised it
wasn't a work thing I think they just
really wanted him to do it
yeah and he's rich it's not like it's so
good but he cheated yeah oh I thought he
was like just so groomsman no he was a
guest and the officiator oh I think he
put it on his corporate card yeah he was
working but like ABC didn't get anything
out of this wedding that it wasn't
televised a to get the exclusive no but
they do get a lot out of it because it
solidifies their their the whole thing
right yeah also one of the toasters
wrote something so interesting is that
more bachelors have married there right
then have married their first two I
didn't realize the only couple who's
married their first choice married is
Catherine and Sean and
guess that's why ABC is like always
putting Shawn places like right and like
thirsting him out cuz like he's a
testament but now yet Jason Mesnick
marrying his second girl and so did Ari
it is so funny yeah
I'm like I love Ari and Lauren and
honestly I think already so hot I love
them too I've always really liked them
like I think they're so great together
and I'm just so happy for them that
they're constantly proving people wrong
yeah you know that like when they were
going through all the [ __ ] a year ago
and everyone was like being so mean to
them they just like all they had to do
was like be patient and just know that
in time like they would show that
they're they are really the narrative
it's hurting um I think that the haters
just have crawled back into their holes
yeah you know because what are they
gonna say now like not only are they
married they have a child on the way so
even if like the marriage didn't work
out they're gonna be in their lives
forever
the bachelor has spun a life a life has
come from that show like and that's
really the highest honor that you can
have like as a show as a dating show is
like we've created life totally this
life wouldn't so now we have a bunch of
engaged couples we have Brian and Rachel
we have Jourdan and Jojo we have how
more no but there was one more a fraud
Oh Karen and Ashley jarred and Ashley
crystal and I was engaged yeah I'm
pretty sure the goose yeah crystal and
Chris they are I think so
couldn't get spire next I think Brian
and Rachel I was gonna say it like
Ashley Jared oh look they're [ __ ] in
love maybe and also they're gonna
probably do a TV but again I don't think
that reach on where I am oh no I don't
think so either cuz like she's a lawyer
unless she makes her money and she
doesn't need that that ABC Matty like
I'm sure Ashley and Jared will get
married this summer in paradise
I'm like just like hardly Nevin did so
like with a little TV special Carly and
they didn't have a their wedding yeah
but like they're happy and did you know
that gypped it's like a word you can't
say why yeah cuz it comes from like
gypsy like being cheap like yeah I
actually just got that out I need to
stop saying it but what's another word
like first for Jerry okay in cancer Wow
never knew now I'm say oh okay say I
didn't warn ya Oh Becca and Garrett
that's where my saying oh they have a
long way to go they're fresh yeah okay
next up Glenn and maybe Colton in and
hopefully have the jury actually no I
hope
not energy I wonder have a long no and
like wet by the time if he got a need
sure by the time that it airs she's
gonna be a superstar and their
relationship will be able handle it
because they're gonna need to settle
down and then all of a sudden like she's
revolving around the world I'm like you
can't make that kind of long-distance
relationship work so he needs he needs
someone who's star like shines a little
duller yeah I agree you know I agree um
Glenn Close and Lady gaga
tie at the Critics Choice Awards okay I
didn't know that the Critics Choice
Awards were like something people went
to I thought it was like the People's
Choice Awards you know yeah see but okay
I don't understand this Romo is the top
winner at the Critics Choice Awards
winning Best Picture foreign language
film and a pair of individual honors for
director Alfonso Cuaron the 24th annual
ceremony held Sunday at Barker hangar in
Santa Monica also split the top actress
award between Glenn Close for the wife
and Lady gaga for a star is born the
split wind comes a week after clothes
won four Golden Globe Award for Best
Actress in total drama but it's like how
did they tie no it's like the thing
about an award is that there is a winner
right and it's almost like obviously
Glenn Close was better and everyone
agreed but they wanted like the
Instagram about moment so they also gave
it to Lady Gaga no but then that wasn't
she only gorgeous that wasn't the only
price that resulted in eighty Adam Amy
Adams and Patricia Arquette's but the
Best Actress but so how many people vote
it like what three and then like alright
is there an even number like because if
it's a million people voting there's no
way half a million and a half a million
so it's probably five people and like
four people two of them voted for you
that's such garbage that's trash I'd be
pissed no and like that's so 2019 let me
this me pick a winner
you made this play actually went up
together and they looked gorgeous I love
that dress are these things even
televised I don't know but they did a
good job I mean she did a good job of
like looking beautiful but not giving it
like a serious look cuz it's not a real
award show and it means nothing like
usually it's like if you get to go to
look like you might get the Oscar gonna
get the Critics Choice Awards and like
you went in at I like it means nothing
no and a tie I can't I can't pick a
winner and did you see her horse side
Lady Gaga I did that was so sad I didn't
know she had a horse yes it was in five
four two
that's really a Malibu ranch that's
really sad I know like animals dying is
like the saddest thing ever no Critics
Choice Awards fake winning one in the
tie makes it even bigger agree the fact
that there could be a tie fake as [ __ ]
yeah the possibility of a tie is what
makes it all the more fake right
you would never have that at the Oscars
so oh yeah please whatever is this
really weird it allowed them to have a
cute moment and you know what I'm here
for both of them so whatever but just
make a choice like it's not that hard by
the way literally doesn't even matter
everyone will be okay I'm sure Lady Gaga
would be like just give it to go in
close I don't think those would when
they give it to Lady I don't want to
come you know I'm not putting this on my
shelf now she had to get all dressed as
a pair of Grammys Oscar attorneys are
you think they're being critic choice
words on that shelf no notes in the
basement wrapped up in newspaper um our
fifth and final story is just taking the
world by storm II Webster I'm so hungry
like I'm gonna die I need to go home and
eat something do you know what the
what's taking the world by storm II
Webster is it daily harvest no it's not
no it's my world by storm right because
now I have food in my house one time I
put a picture of my fridge in in my
Instagram stories and people were like
you don't have food and I didn't think
it was weird to say I have a fully
stocked fridge with drinks and that's it
and then people if you don't keep food
in your house I'm like no I just order
any one I want but now I started keeping
freedom and changed my life because I
got a box from daily harvest and like
it's just food ready for me it's
incredible I got it
we put in orders for daily harvest I was
on my way home I was up in the elevator
I got this box I was literally like
looking for something to order on my
phone and like sometimes there's just
nothing that sounds good or nothing
that's fresh enough and I opened this
box and was all these like ready to make
the little meals healthy ass [ __ ]
and it was so excited I didn't order
anything I had like a bowl that was like
quinoa and what's it called Zac are like
delicious like something that I would
never eat and was so filling and so
healthy so daily harvest delivers
carefully sourced chef's crafted food
built of fruits and vegetables you can
get up to fifty ready to blend smoothies
savory harvest bowls soups and breakfast
balls if you go to jail - Harvest calm
and enter promo code toast you can get
three cups for ray in your first order
that's promo code toast for three free
daily harvest cups at daily - harvest
comm daily - harvest com
I'm doing it I can't believe I food in
my house like it's I really feel like a
grown-up I can't believe I didn't know
about this sooner because it's like a
meal I don't really have to cook but
it's like I take the requires a little
bit of cooking so I feel like a chef no
you feel like it's like oh my right
feel like I finally like used the
kitchen and I'm getting like so many
nutrients and I don't have to order in
and like you know there was this is more
lolly in it I could tell it's the
nutrients and it's the glow of the NWO
of course and it's also its breakdown no
I don't want an oh I'm getting one this
week interesting okay but the swear
that's taking the world by storm
I can't wait wait satire like I know I
know the story that's taking the world
by unlike chickpeas and and carrots I
like carrots um the story that's taking
the world by storm are you do you know
when am I gonna say oh is it a Jeff
Bezos yeah okay
you guys the last time we spoke about
this was just you know they were
announcing their divorce he was seeing
local news anchor local news anchor you
know it at first it seemed like they
were just you know starting to date and
now all the salaciousness is coming out
and it's really [ __ ] wild because not
only like were they having an affair but
like there are text messages now we have
text messages that have been shared with
the National Enquirer which was which
was a weird choice to leak to maybe they
were giving the highest amount money
they're the only ones who aren't scared
of just Jeff Bezos right I don't know
Bezos shared wife's pillow talk with
mistress and boasted about u2's bono
Randi tech tycoon
we've never reported from the National
Enquirer before and they use the word
Randi and for that reason I honestly
like the National Enquirer is like I
just grace like they should be called
the national disgrace for sure but like
they have the story of the yearly brandy
tech tycoon Jeff Bezos shared bedroom
talk with his long-suffering wife to his
mistress as the suspecting spouse began
to question him about their affair in
another blockbuster text message
exchange obtained by the National
Enquirer
braggadocious billionaire Bezos confided
to his lover Lauren Sanchez the wife of
powerful Hollywood mogul Patrick
Whitesell in September this is what he
texted to his woman his mistress
McKenzie dreamt i redecorated the
bedroom I kept doing it and it got
weirder and weirder and weirder until I
was sewing stuff turtles into the
comforter wife said that's not hard to
interpret the disclosure of his pillow
talk text shatters Bezos insistence that
the illicit affair did not torpedo his
144 billion dollar marriage to the woman
who helped him start Amazon 20
years ago turtles in a dream are
supposedly an indication enclosed
personality and suggests a period of
slow progress in someone's life imagine
you make this [ __ ] imagine if the
National Enquirer like Majan if the
public knew what you were dreaming about
it's so it was also like then
interpreting and speaking to your
subconscious right right so it's not
only [ __ ] that you put out there it's
like things that you don't even know
that your thing right quote around the
time were pens II also started to use
brighter lipsticks and wear a tighter
dresses to try and win back just
attention to source explained in another
text sent on September 11th the horndog
honcho praised mom of three Sanchez for
advising him to contact rocker bono of
u2 quote Lauren I'm in love with you
deep I know it sounds strange but even
little things like you suggesting I
asked for extra training from Bell make
my love for you expand and grow makes me
think of when you told me to ask Bono
for music permission your energy and
ideas and competence and spirit turned
me on okay wait no here's the thing
how did they get these text messages
hold on there's mark okay I am so full
of love for you my heart is growing just
so it can have room for you it's bigger
than it's ever been and it's still
swelling when you know what's so funny
is like you think like the most powerful
man in the world like has better game
than my heart is growing Lauren I'm in
love with you Oh deep okay we got there
or do you think didn't know how these
text messages we're going I mean it's
like was it ass for her I don't know cuz
her Twitter where are her responses
right oh yeah look we're together
where is her talking about her husband
who's a big deal to his hot her
husband's dreams is he's still with his
Jeff Bezos still with Lauren yes
according to page six they're still
together even and so Lauren is getting
divorced - or she was already divorced
I'm assuming she's getting divorced now
this is like the most crazy like the two
of them are a wrecking ball and they're
taking out everyone every marriage every
person every business in their in their
way there's another quote go I'm June
1st 2018 he sent a message that's a long
time ago this is a Wilder well you know
what I want I want to get a little drunk
with you tonight not falling down just a
little drunk I want to talk to you
and plan with you listened and laugh I
basically caps want to be with you like
honestly like I don't know how I text
and don't want to fall asleep with you
and wake up tomorrow and read the paper
with you and have coffee with you I
can't read this anymore it's giving me a
pit it's like if Jeff Bezos a man who
was acutely aware of people's personal
information get results because you know
he takes people's personal information
and sells it so if he's so aware and it
not only did it happen to him but this
is what he sends knowing that this is
how the world were if it happens to him
like what's gonna happen to us it's just
this is serious know so let's go and
stop it from happening to him like oh my
god let's talk about the messages
because like I don't know if you were to
find my text messages I mean I never
[ __ ] respond to people and if I do
it's truly just like lol I don't think
you could find anything nearly as
embarrassing as that but like that's
really embarrassing I wanna yeah and
it's like so on the one hand he's I
don't maybe there are like sex ed or
like dirty and raunchy and please don't
make me like read those right but um I'm
so this is like him like his romantic
like prose you know like him but that's
the best he has it's like reading the
newspaper this is like poetry it's so
it's so embarrassing like honestly my
thoughts go out to the whole Bezos
family because this is Sarah yeah to the
wife and the children how many kids does
he have three oh how did like I cam
Bolinas is happening and now like people
are questioning his judgement is like a
CEO of the biggest sorry
I'm able to separate the two and the
biggest company in the world is greatest
thing that ever happened to me and like
let's not let this be a point like
reflection on Amazon because I [ __ ]
love Amazon and like leave them alone
except for like you can move your
headquarters out of New York but besides
that like this sounds fine let's leave
Amazon out of this okay who owns the
other like 80% of Amazon I don't know
70% I don't know like shareholders is
it's a publicly traded company yeah yeah
you can my stocks so maybe that's who
owns it perhaps can be its mouth
Amazon suck I I got I gotta get into
stocks yeah easier burden it up okay
also just there we just um didn't unison
that was the fifth story and then I just
wanted to i pulled up another just to
make note of the fact that the game of
thrones final season premiere date has
been revealed
April 14th winter is coming Jackie said
um the trailer and boy was it chilling
literally and physically I'm so excited
like we haven't lived in a world with
Game of Thrones since before we had Theo
so now we have Korea the toast totally
will have Theo toast and Game of Thrones
all at once I'm so excited
well I was watching the trailer last
night and the trailer shows Sansa Jon
Snow and Arya and it's just so funny
because like you knew throughout the
show you knew that like certain
characters were special and you knew
that they were gonna make it to whatever
the end is and like they they're never
gonna be killed off and Jon Snow was
definitely one of them so long no that
[ __ ] at the wall I was like so stupid
but you knew he was special
I didn't yes you did because whatever I
didn't know he was special like till
like maybe like season 3 [ __ ] no I'm
just saying throughout oh yeah you knew
she was special
yeah Sansa like I never got the special
vibe room when she was being stupid and
like Geoffrey and they got her sister in
trouble and like they ate and her
parents killed like okay right so the
cheese wouldn't leave that she didn't
give me special bond no but she and the
fact that she's like the last Starks
standing with the three of them like
really of this dumb [ __ ] agree but she
know now she says strong much and I like
and then she was punished in space I
don't know for sure but like in even in
the trailer like the three of them are
down in the thing and then like
obviously the White Walkers are coming
and Arya grabs her sword and Jon Snow
grabs us were like [ __ ] salads is
useless she doesn't have a sword she
can't even help no now which we can look
pretty yeah maybe her hair is like fire
or something maybe that'd be good no I
don't she has no power it's like she's
no maybe she is useless but she the only
thing that can kill White Walkers fire
and steel okay she has no powers
what's kind of steel um Valyrian steel
I'm so excited I don't see the recaps
are gonna be so great I'm oh my god I
can't wait like I've missed this so much
in and right now when I'm struggling
with is like I can't find anything to
watch and because there's nothing I mean
you should watch we start Game of
Thrones yeah because honestly it's so
complex and the more knowledge you have
like you're really not in encyclopedia
you remember so that a but he read the
books my renamed
and he is just like a smart guy like if
I have any questions you got to call him
like he's truly a game of Thrones
encyclopedia like the more you know in
Game of Thrones world like lingo people
history the more learning of a viewer
you are and like the more you can
predict what's going to happen because
by the way if you rewatch it they tell
you every there but if segments in fake
Old English that you don't understand
they're still being like ominous things
said that turn out to be true right
like Sansa I mean like Daenerys and John
being related right which is like the
grossest most amazing thing the most
amazing thing and I know that one of
them has to die in order like by the end
of it are you saying yeah they're not
both gonna live in and and have power I
think that Daenerys wins John they're
not gonna he's not gonna kill him but
he's gonna just die in combat they were
prince and princess and they were really
didn't it's just too good to be true
that everyone that you love is gonna
live in ruins you know people have to
die along the way right right and her
dragons are gonna die too
you think yeah I think one no no don't
tell me a prediction cuz you're always
right about [ __ ] and then I did not
surprise anymore for sure and there's
definitely something weird about Chuck
Terry stop okay I [ __ ] love Tyrion
you knew he was special you knew he was
gonna make it to the end you know you
knew anyways
that's our show for you today yeah what
a great show I feel so relaxed hopefully
this was better than last week
oh my god even better that's why I'm
Ashley you guys don't want to replace me
they should be a permanent co-host oh
sorry I do four shows this week and I'm
amazing I gave it all my all Marvel
comes in on Friday that was the best job
[ __ ] I'm already mad at her anyways we
will see you back here tomorrow maybe or
we will have watched about or maybe not
you know all tuned in sporadic
sporadically I hope that sporadically of
course and yeah that's that's all sure
you guys should definitely be filing
public no job because he has had a
social media revamp and it's premium and
so I am headed out next you see Tiffany
Thornton on ESA of course I did homegirl
Bassam everything she was a desperate
housewife she ate the cake and brie
yelled at her you know ever see that
yeah she like dipped her finger in the
cake a brie was like are you [ __ ]
kidding
that's hilarious um I'm headed back out
on the road where am I going
February 10th ammonia in Huntington Long
Island to edit a second show because the
first one sold out and I think that's it
I'm headed to Mexico this weekend if you
have any good Punta Mita recommendations
please don't send them my way just like
I'm not leaving
love you guys hope you have a great day
bye
you